[Music]
well today the Department of Justice
threatened 23 sanctuary cities counties
and states with subpoenas if they don't
turn over certain records in response
New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio and several
other city leaders boycotted a scheduled
meeting with the president at the White
House today David Campos is an attorney
he's a former member of the San
Francisco Board of Supervisors and he
joins us tonight miss Campos thanks for
coming on thank you very much and I'm
here as deputy County Executive for the
County of Santa Clara here in Santa
Clara County great County so because you
have that official role in California I
ask you this
you're Attorney General Xavier Becerra
announced last week that employers in
the state who cooperate with federal
immigration authorities will be
prosecuted by the state of California
which apparently is now its own country
will you participate in this if you find
in your County employers collaborating
with the US government on immigration
law will you turn them in to the state
of California for prosecution I think
I'm good enough a lawyer to know that
before I answer that I have to look at
the specifics of that what I can tell
you is about the County of Santa Clara
we are proud to call ourselves a
constitutional County that is trying to
follow the letter in the spirit of the
US Constitution and that's why when it
comes to immigration we're very clear
that we are here to do the job that is
outlined for us by the US Constitution
we actually have sued the Trump
administration twice and succeeded in
every time where they have attempted to
predicate federal funding to force
counties like Santa Clara to be in the
business of enforcing immigration law
right and with all due respect we
believe that there is a role for the
federal government and there's a role
for jurisdictions like Santa
since since you're a lawyer who helps
run a big County in the biggest state
answer this is it consistent with
readings of the Constitution ratified by
the Supreme Court that a state would
actively work to undermine federal law
well I'll answer it for you no actually
no that's not happened since the Civil
War so what's your take on that as a
county official and a lawyer well you
know I I don't think that I
be in the business of telling the state
or the federal government how to do
their job likewise I don't think that
they should tell us how to do our job
you know I have an order here that was
issued in the Northern District of
California where the federal district
court basically told told President
Trump in his Department of Justice with
all due respect sir you cannot force
counties like Santa Clara to do your job
that's not their role right but we're
arguing parallel I'm sorry we're having
parallel conversations I'm not asking
about whether you have a duty to do your
job I'm asking you whether you're
allowed as an official in the state of
California to actively undermine federal
law and prosecute Californians who
follow it really simple and you know
that a distinction because you're an
attorney and I'm asking you would you do
that if you were ordered by the Attorney
General of your state to help prosecute
somebody or aid in a prosecution of a
California citizen because he followed
federal law would you participate in
that well look again I don't know the
specifics of this program we would then
let me have it then this is we're
getting nowhere I think this is
something you should think about though
because we're moving toward a
constitutional crisis really fast as you
know as a lawyer let me ask you this so
you believe obviously that having more
undocumented immigrants illegal aliens
whatever people who aren't legally
supposed to be here in your County is a
good thing have you done an economic
impact study on immigration in Santa
Clara County well let me first of all
tell you mr. Carlson and I thank you for
the opportunity it's a personal issue
for me my parents brought me here
undocumented as a child I was 14 ok and
what I can tell you is that when I came
here it wasn't my choice but I made a
point of trying to be a productive
members of I don't want to be my study I
think that's great I think it's great
I'm not attacking you personally no
there a lot of immigrants like you who
are impressive but they're also 330
million Americans who already citizens
and I think it's fair to ask what effect
does this have on them so if you studied
the economic effect of immigration on
your county and if you haven't and I
know you haven't why don't you tell me
why you haven't well I actually we
believe that the immigrants that are
part of our County are an asset to our
County
but you know that and you say why why
wouldn't you study it and just rather
than just guess I mean look if you
actually look at the contributions that
immigrants make on a daily basis whether
it's education and the creation of jobs
businesses I'm sure this shot works
because it looks like it does studies
have been made that actually
jurisdictions that are not in the
business of enforcing immigration law
are actually safer and we're actually
engaging in as you know to say you know
what stop demonizing any one group
whether it's I get it I get it I could
do with a little less moralizing and a
little more care to the effect of these
policies on actual people based in
numbers and social science which you
could do but are choosing not to sorry
I'm out of time I can't post thank you